for eight centuries it's been hailed as
the document which gave birth to English
democracy and justice for copies of the
Magna Carta still exist one of the two
in the British Library is so badly
damaged it's illegible but the Royal
Seal of Approval curtailed the monarchs
power it was written in Latin but the
English translation contains words which
are still enshrined in law today but the
most important thing about Magna Carta
was that it established the principle of
the rule of law no free man shall be
seized or imprisoned or stripped of his
rights or outlawed or exiled except by
the judgement of his equals all by the
law of the land and that Clause is
really at the heart of Magna Carta same
today and yet this was a deal between a
tyrannical King and powerful barons it
didn't apply to ordinary people King
John had imposed heavy taxes on his
barons in order to pay from his
expensive foreign Wars if they refused
to pay he punished them severely or
seized their property the Barons
demanded that King John obey the law
when he refused they captured London and
John was forced to negotiate the two
sides met at Runnymede to hammer out a
peace treaty they'd all be amazed at how
their Great Charter is still revered
today this monument was paid for by
American lawyers after all the Magna
Carta was valid for just ten weeks
the Pope declared that King John had
signed it under duress and had it
annulled so how come a failed treaty has
become such a worldwide symbol of
democracy that the current monarch will
be among those celebrating its 800th
anniversary the Magna Carta was revised
and read written over the years its
principles were adopted by America's
founding fathers and their Declaration
of Independence and a Bill of Rights so
much so that the country has loaned
copies of both documents to the British
Library it inspired the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and has been
quoted by Gandhi and Mandela but critics
say modern politicians don't always
respect its principles the war on terror
has led to prolonged detention without
trial
all these things do not sit comfortably
with the spirit of Magna Carta and it
does give an example where throughout
the world not just America not just the
United Kingdom politicians name-check
Magna Carta when perhaps they should be
living its spirit a little more than
that and while David Cameron will join
the 800th anniversary celebrations
he's also considering withdrawing
Britain from the European Convention and
scrapping the human rights act there is
something that we need to learn from
again from the Charter which is that if
you want other people to respect rights
you have also got yourself to respect
those rights I happen to believe that
although it's not perfect both the
Convention and the Human Rights Act are
working pretty well the Magna Carta
started a debate on our rights as
citizens which will continue long into
the future in woods Sky News Runnymede